- [Voiceover] Each square
on the a grid is unit square
with an area of one square centimeter.
So each of these squares
is one square centimeter.
This is one square centimeter,
and this is one square
centimeter, and so on.
And now we're asked, what
is the area of the figure?
By figure I'm sue they mean this bluish,
purplish quadrilateral,
and we wanna know its area.
And area is talking about how
much space the shape covers.
How much space does this
quadrilateral cover?
How many square centimeters
does the quadrilateral cover?
To figure it out, we
could start by counting.
Here's one.
Here's one square centimeter
the quadrilateral covers,
and I can keep counting like that,
all of the square
centimeters that I can see.
Here's two, three.
Another row's got some here.
Four, five, six.
Down here, here's seven.
Eight, nine.
So there's nine full square centimeters.
Nine square centimeters,
but that's not the entire area.
That's not everything it covers.
It also covers these small parts,
these triangle-shaped
little spaces of area,
and so we need to count those too.
Let's look over here.
Let's look, if we drew
one of these triangles
into a unit square, and
then we drew another one
on the other half of this unit square,
we would see that combined
they make one full unit square.
So we can do that.
We can take this triangle up here,
which is half of a unit
square and combine it
with this half of a unit square.
So if we combine these two together,
that's one more unit square.
Now we have nine full unit
squares plus one more.
But there's still more of
them, so we can keep combining.
This half unit square
combined with the other one
on the bottom makes a second unit square,
and finally, there's two
more halves here, one, two,
which combine to make another whole.
So we have nine full unit squares plus,
plus three more unit squares
that we made by combining.
We made one by combining these
two, a second unit square
with these two, and a
third unit square here.
So we have nine full unit squares
and then three more unit
squares we put together,
which is a total of 12
square units or 12 square,
in this case our unit is
centimeters, 12 square centimeters.
Our figure, our quadrilateral
covers 12 square centimeters,
so it has an area of
12 square centimeters.